because people are stupid nowadays we
have to do a disclaimer so all things
comedy are not advocating that you use
these weapons on anybody make them buy
them anything illegal
just trying to save your lives from
messin with old dudes whatever you do
you do not fight old men okay now cuz
they're old now cuz you're gonna hurt
them is because they will destroy you
[Music]
welcome to the degenerate gentleman show
I'm your host brenards and I'm Alex
Monaco and today we're gonna talk about
old man weapons you don't want to mess
with old guys first off they have this
old man strength because they've been
working since I third grade and they
have old man tricks to hurt you they
could take you down by your thumb they
can hit you with a kidney punch you
don't even see coming oh good one shot
you went to the bathroom in your pants
and you're on the ground crying you
don't agree with the umpire on TV that's
never gonna hear him anyways you're
getting a smack in the back of the head
if you shake an old man's hand and not
look him in the eyes you could lose your
life you take your dog on a walk you
don't bring a bag you're getting a thumb
to the neck you take his parking space
you're done you're dead Plus old men
carry these weapons on him okay so
you've been warned because they will
kill you and if they do it'll probably
be with one of these weapons okay I'm
gonna show you some typical old man
weapons now the first thing I'm gonna
pull out for you which these are illegal
to have we had to actually get paperwork
for this these were called brass
knuckles old men used to love these back
in the day they could come up behind you
you see them in the movies a lot but
it's a straight shot and you know it's
self-explanatory
the next one that was pretty popular
which again is illegal very simple was a
switchblade every old guy carries a
switchblade or a knife in general by the
way some laws are different if it's
bigger than four fingers it's illegal
again the switch blades illegal but we
had to fill out paperwork for it but
every old guy used to carry these back
in the day now what we're really gonna
talk about is oh man weapons y'all say
anymore now first up I have what is
called a blackjack it's a piece of
leather and they would stick a piece of
lead in here so a lot of muggers and
people back in the day would use this if
you were walking by they come up behind
you smack in the back of the head and it
knocks you out say you're having words
at me like hey you owe me 10 cents for
that drink but only enough okay fine and
then both you died it's over the next
weapon I want to show you is a really a
weapon but it's so roll of quarters
we're doing laundry no we're not doing
laundry all right basically back in a
day you use the roll of quarters to load
your hand here put put your hand out to
feel all heavy this is how your hand
weighs normally right this is a normal
normal fist with the loaded quarters it
becomes much heavy
right thing a lot of old guys like to
load their hand and then they'll clock
you from the side it's an instant
knockout it really does suck now if your
quarters breaking your hand and like you
lose a quarter roll the next thing you
can do which is this is a very common
old man weapon you could take change and
put it in a sock
you have to double sock it off tie a
knot at the top and this now becomes
weapon the quarters in the sock can act
as a blackjack old guys would come
around and just you know you can swing
it cracky right in the head with it
right it's not just changed you could
put in here you could put screws nuts
bolts mind you old guys they were very
innovative and very violent next artist
is and you know what this all I know
what that is David you've never hit a
home run with one of these happens just
inside the park good old-fashioned
Louisville Slugger this is very legal
however it's illegal to have it in your
car by itself so old-school guys would
have a baseball bat in the trunk but
they would also have a glove and a
baseball because if they pulled it out
and they used it then it by itself it's
a weapon but if they had the glove and
the ball then they could say hey we were
out playing baseball old dudes are
resourceful last but not least we have
the axe handle what is an axe handle
it's exactly what it is an accident the
head of the axe goes here
right but what old guys do is they don't
what they don't carry an axe with them
no no what they do is they put a nail at
the end of it now a lot of old dudes
have been known even with baseball bats
to hammer pin nails all throughout it so
it acts like a medieval mace this is
some Braveheart closed casket type stuff
if you really get an old man mad this is
probably the weapon he's going to use on
you to make sure you don't see another
day I'm officially scared shitless
[Music]
so this concludes this episode of
degenerate gentleman make sure you
follow us on all social media Facebook
Instagram Twitter YouTube in addition to
all things comedy and remember that's
because you're a degenerate doesn't mean
you stop acting like a gentleman Alex
you know what really gets me going
broads know baseball one man who's what
part of a team Ty Cobb Babe Ruth and so
on
one man oh it's the worse than your own
pressure